hi in this video I'm going to talk about
x-ray crystallography and x-ray
crystallography is a very efficient
method in protein biochemistry and if we
want to understand the 3d structure of
protein and how the amino acids are
arranged in a 3d space then X x-ray
crystallography is our weapon we have
two weapons NMR and x-ray
crystallography
but NMR we can't do NMR for a protein
which is more than twenty kilo Dalton
the protein which are less than twenty
kilo Dalton or equal to twenty kilo
Dalton then we can solve their
structures with NMR but for uh protein a
greater than twenty kilo Dalton x-ray
crystallography roughy is the only way
and we are very familiar with x-ray and
the problem with our conventional
microscopy technique is our microscopy
can actually show us the cellular
details but it can't show us the
molecular details or how atoms and
molecules are actually arranged in the
3d plane so for if we want to visualize
the double helix structure of the DNA
and how the bases are arranged
microscopy can't show it if we want to
see the amino acids how the amino acids
are arranged in a protein microscopy can
tell us about these things and which can
tell us about these things at at least
extraterrestial if we can give a clue
about these things so we would look at
the principles behind exit
crystallography and how we can use x-ray
crystallography for protein biochemistry
so let's talk about x-ray a little bit
so x-ray let's see where extra lies in
our visible spectrum so if we draw a
line to denote our visible spectrum then
first we would have gamma rays then we
would have x-rays then we would have
what we called the UV and then we have
the visible range so the x-rays have
very low wavelength and the wavelength
is in nanometer order and this is very
important we would understand it in a
moment and
now the extra crystallography is
actually dependent upon the x-ray
diffraction the diffraction what is
diffraction diffraction is a phenomenon
of bending of light now we know that
light traveling a straight path
then why the bending light can even bend
around edges or any slits provided that
the slit or the edge would be in a
comparable of dimension with that
particular wavelength of that light so
the visible light can easily bend around
our slit but the x-ray would only bend
around and diffracted when it is passed
through our lattice of protein so in
order to understand more we would see
the Bragg's law so for x-ray
crystallography the basic scheme means
what we have to do is we have to first
we have to crystallize our protein
solution that we want to know the
structure about the protein then what we
would do we would shine x-ray you would
sign x-ray on that protein and we as we
expect the egg that a crystal would
deflect the x-ray and the x-ray would
deflect it in all directions and it
would give us actually a diffraction
pattern which would somewhat look like
this there are many diffraction spots
after getting the diffraction spot we
would do our mathematics and what we
would do we would actually Fourier
transform this thing and what we would
get after these diffraction pattern we
would get something which is called
electron density map and this electron
density map is very important so this is
our basic scheme for electron density
map so once we have our electron density
map then we try to fit our atoms and
molecules in
side that electron density map and we
would exactly look for a perfect match
or perfect fit just like a jigsaw puzzle
and after that after doing that
following some algorithms and statistics
what we would get we would ultimately
get up we would ultimately able to build
our 3d model so here arbitrary 3d model
I am building so we are able to build a
3d model of the protein in this way we
could derive the structural information
from the x-ray crystallography
experiment now let's see a little bit
about a Bragg's law and x-ray
diffraction so inside this crystal that
I have drawn previous previously we
would have lattice lattice means
three-dimensional arrangement of these
protein molecules so here we would have
many lattice points apart from the
lattice point there are atoms in these
corners so these are basic unit cells so
what we would expect let's draw it in a
2d diagram so here we have lot of
lattice points and here is a deeper
layer of this lattice point
corresponding to this and even more
deeper lattice point corresponding to
this now what would happen we would
shine x-ray and x-ray would fall on our
particular lattice point and it would be
diffracted the intra-atomic distance is
in nanometer order and the extra
wavelength is also in nanometer order
that is why diffraction could take place
when x-ray falls on to these crystal
lattice now if we see another x-ray
falling even a deeper lattice plane it
would be also diffracted now if we just
analyze these two beams and the phase of
these two beams what we would see that
let's call it a and let's call it B
what we would see that these beam be
have to travel a little bit more
distance little bit more path than beam
a now if we draw a perpendicular and
call this total distance X so it would
be also X but here is a portion which is
extra we call it Delta X and also when
the wave gets back it returns also it
has to travel our extra path Delta X so
the net extra path that the wave have to
travel the wave we have to travel is 2
Delta X this is the extra path that wave
we have to travel now if we denote the
inter-atomic distance as D and this is
the incidence angle theta what we would
see that this angle will also be theta
this angle inside would also be theta so
this is also D and from there we can
derive that the value of x would be
actually d times sine theta so the value
of 2 Delta X would be actually 2 D sine
theta so this is the net path difference
between a this is net path difference
between a and B x-rays and this path
difference is 2 D sine theta and as per
Bragg's law as per Bragg's law this
distance is equal to in lambda where n
could be so 2 D sine theta is equal to n
lambda where n could be an integer like
n could be 1 2 3 or even n could be half
- half etcetera when n is like this 1 2
and three it would do our constructive
interference when any infraction it
would do our destructive indifference
now what is constructive interference
and destructive interference and why we
would see a constructive and destructive
interference at all so when there is a
path difference as we know there is also
a phase difference corresponding to a
path difference so these x-ray that
these B x-rays actually phase-shifted
now when it is reflected and or
scattered there is a chance that it
would interfere with a if we if it
interferes constructively then what we
would get we would get another wave with
a high amplitude let's see
say for instance this is our axis and
here is our wave a these are with a and
this is our wave P and from this drawing
you can understand that the crest and
trough of these a and B are exactly
similar so these two waves are in phase
so they would actually interfere
constructively forming a resultant wave
which have even are more amplitude to d2
if these amplitude is a and a this
amplitude would be doing now what we
would see we would see the destructive
interference ultimately the destructive
interference or destructive interference
it is our beam a and here is our beam B
and they are actually out of phase and
if they have same amplitude then that
their resultant wave would not produce
any resultant wave it is a destructive
interference and if their amplitudes
vary then it will produce a wave whose
amplitude result and amplitude would be
reduced so therefore here the take-home
message is that the mob difference would
correspond to a phase difference and due
to phase difference we would get our
interference
pattern a diffraction pattern or
interference pattern what you whatever
you can see interference pattern or
diffraction pattern and analyzing that
diffraction pattern and Fourier
transform this diffraction pattern we
would get a density map and after
getting the density map we can fit we
would try to fit our atoms and molecules
inside that density map and we would end
up getting a protein model and we have
to validate this protein model by
putting it into the Ramachandran plot
and we have to plot its Phi and sy
angles and we have to validate our
protein structure in these by putting it
into our Ramachandran plot so this is
all about the x-ray crystallography I
hope you enjoyed and hope you liked it
please subscribe thank you